i believe that um 99  of what financial advisors and wealth  managers  do for people you can learn  in a month okay and here's the thing  the world i have friends who are  financial advisors and wealth managers  okay guys the beautiful people there's  lots of industries that we don't really  need  i have lots of friends that are realtors  ninety percent of what realtors  do could be replaced by uh just working  with a lawyer a little bit earlier and  changing some systems around but today's  not about realtors it's about financial  advisors and wealth managers  okay um in one here's the reality  financial advisors and wealth managers  make money  by convincing you that it's really  difficult to manage this stuff for  yourself  and oftentimes um  it's just not